Das Podcast-Urvorum sendet aus dem Mittelalter mittels Eselantennen Florentin Will, Stefan Dietze und wir die Zuhörer für Podcast-Urvorum. Einen wunderschönen guten Tag. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast Ufo. Ich dachte Arte. Es klang wie jede Sendung von Arte. Nein, Das Podcast Ufo. Wir sind hier nicht bei Karabolage oder einer anderen Arte-Sendung, die ich alle mal gesehen habe. Nein, wir sind bei Podcast Ufo und nichtsdestoweniger intellektuell gesättigt mit Stefan Tietze. Hallo, herzlich willkommen. Flore, Team Will ist auch dabei. Danke und gerne. Schreibt euch gerne was raus, macht den Blog auf, gerne Notizen schreiben, ist gern gesehen. Weil diese Folge ist klausurrelevant. Richtig und sie ist vollgestopft mit klugen Sachen. Stefan Tietze hat hier schon den Bauch voll, er hat richtig viel gelesen, Adorno, Horkheimer sind da drin und alles drin. Vielleicht fallen ja einige Zitate heute, die ihr irgendwann euch ins Fleisch stechen lasst, als Tattoo. Vielleicht irgendwie sowas macht das kaputt, was dich kaputt macht oder so, so Klassiker, Sätze. Vielleicht falsch auch, völlig richtig. Aber am Anfang war gesagt, jedem Anfang wohnt ein Zauber-Eine. Ah, okay, ja, das ist aber nicht von dir, ne? Nee. War das nicht, das war das Hitler, ne? Auch?
Ja, Hitler. Ja, schau.
Hitler 33.
Ja, da hatten wir alle noch andere.
Naja, Stefan, was glaubst du denn, was ist der meist, was meinst du denn, was ist der meist tätowierte Satz?
Ja, vielleicht sowas wie akab oder kann ich mir vor alles was vier buchstaben hat und das ist ja rage love sowas ja disco ist dead but punk is not dead ich habe nur ich gedacht irgendwie habe ich auch eine komische vorstellung obwohl viele leute die ich sehr gut kenne und mir sehr nahe stehen, haben Tattoos. Aber ich habe immer die Vorstellung, dann sieht man so einen voll tätowierten, grimmig dreinblickenden Menschen in schwarzen Sachen und ich habe immer so ein bisschen Angst vor dem. Und dann habe ich neulich gedacht, der muss ja auch seine Schnürsenkel zumachen. Weißt du, der muss ja auch. Ja, das stimmt. Manchmal hat man so Momente, wo man denkt man denkt so der krasseste oscar gewinner musste ja auch morgens zähne putzen so joe biden ja weiß ich nicht der vielleicht nicht der muss vielleicht den gebiss aus rausnehmen aus dem tasse neben ihm ich will jetzt nicht in diese kerbe schlagen ja irgendwie welche politische richtung möchtest du Aber ich bin reingetappt. In welche Richtung willst du uns hier drängen? Das war nicht politisch gemeint.
Wie gesagt, wir drängen mich jetzt nicht. Schubst mich in diese Richtung. Nein, das stimmt schon. Oh, oh, ich bin reingefallen. Menschen, die man respektiert, irgendwie, Leonardo DiCaprio hat auch manchmal innen an der Backe so ein bisschen so ein geschwollenes Stück, wo man dann immer so drauf rumkaut, mit der Hunger rangeht, so da ist der nicht vorgefeiert Auch der hat mal beim Lunchen hat er wahrscheinlich so ein Basilikum-Blatt, irgendwie zwischen den Zähnen vorne. Zwischen den wunderbaren, perfekten Zähnen war dann so ein Basilikum-Blatt. Und sieht's, das ist meine Frage, sieht's dann nicht noch auffälliger aus, als von meinen schiefen gelben Zähnchen? Ich verstehe, wenn du dich selbst zur Leinwand machst, dann ist plötzlich alles der Federstrich des Schicksals. Vielleicht sowas, ja, lasst euch das gerne tätowieren. Ihr merkt, das Podcast-Ufo ist kultiviert jetzt. Genau, und falls ihr mal ein Tattoo machen wollt, schaut gerne vorbei bei tattoo-tattoo-tattoo.de mit dem Gutscheincode TATTOO. Ufo, das Podcast ist der Gutscheincode dafür. Der, die, das, Podcast muss mit.
Erlebst du dich auch manchmal zu Hause, kurz behind the scenes mässig, dass du bei
einer neuen App, die man irgendwie runterlädt,
immer erst mal den Code Ufo
versuchst, in der Hoffnung, weil
man auch denkt, hatten wir das nicht mal.
Ja, genau. Ich denke, das ist mittlerweile
bei allem so. Haben wir das nicht schon mal
im Zweifel. Muss ich das jetzt,
also kann ich mich da selber auch als ich oder muss man da sich dann den digitalen schnurrbart vorklemmen dieses klassische wahrscheinlich der am wenigsten verstandene satz der geschichte ist ja der rechtsweg ist ausgeschlossen was so ist so okay ja klar nee nee den werde ich den rechtsweg werde ich nicht den werde ich nicht aber ist das ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung. Hä, aber du kannst den Rechtsweg ja nicht ausschliessen. Also du kannst viel machen. Er wurde schon. Hallo, du kannst im Kapitalismus viel machen, aber den Rechtsweg ausschliessen. Nichts ist unmöglich. Dream big. Greif nach den Sternen, wenn du den Rechtsweg ausschliessen willst, Stefan. Denn der einzige, der dir da im Weg steht, bist du selbst. Und sobald du dich selbst mal zur Seite getackelt hast, sobald du dich zur Seite mit so einem Fusskick direkt über der Bodenfläche deinem eigenen Ich die Füsse unter den Boden wegziehst, kannst du auch den Rechtsweg ausschliessen. Ich habe vergessen, wo diese Metapher anfing. Du kannst ihn ausschliessen. Für alle, die den Notarien da draußen haben, ihr könnt ihn ausschliessen, ihr schafft es, schliesst ihn aus.
Aber meine blöde Frage jetzt, um das mal zu challengen jetzt. Wir schreiben in unsere Podcast-Beschreibung rein, der Rechtswirk ist ausgeschlossen. Und dann spielen wir 19 Mal am Stück Lady Gaga Pokerface. Wie gross schätzt die Wahrscheinlichkeit ein, dass da Anwälte sagen, ah schein. Hallo, mein Name ist Christian Solmecke, Rechtsanwalt und Partner bei WBS Legal in Köln.
Und falls ihr kein Video mehr verpassen wollt, dann lasst doch mal einen Daumen da. Stefan und Florentin haben in ihrem Podcast über das Thema, den Satz, der Rechtsweg ist ausgeschlossen gesprochen. Damit haben sie mich auch besiegt, ich kann das nicht anfassen. Bevor wir uns diesem Thema widmen, ganz kurz noch, vielleicht seid ihr auch betreffend vom Deezer-Daten-Lag.
Ich habe zu viele Videos geguckt, in kurzer Zeit, aber den fände ich wirklich spannend. Ich glaube, jeder Anwalt, das ist so wie Knoblauch bei Vampiren, jeder Anwalt, der dem zu nahe kommt, so schmilzt so ins Gesicht langsam, weil der ist einfach ausgeschlossen, da haben die keine Macht. Ich stelle mir vor, wie die Lady Gaga-Anwälte da so sitzen, viele Anwälte, wahrscheinlich viele, die in so einem penthouse, in so einem gruseligen, gruselig dreinschauenden penthouse irgendwo im Nebel hängen und die die ganze Zeit warten auf Leute wie wir, die 19 mal nacheinander Pokerface spielen. Und dann wird dann so eine Goldgrube, es bricht gelöste Stimmung aus, die Sektkorken knallen und dann stossen sie auf den Satz, der Rechtswege ist aber ausgeschlossen.
Und dann der einzig deutschsprachende Hans, what does it mean? Und Hans, der einzig Deutschsprachende, sagt, no, it's no good. It's no good. It's the right way is cancelled. The right way is cancelled? Hans, what does that mean? It's not out. What does that mean? We can't go there. What does it mean, the right way is- I know you want to go there, but we can't. Don't mess with thatverleihung live gesehen, denn ich war in der Zeitzone, dazu gleich vielleicht ein bisschen mehr. Aber die Oscars habe ich live gesehen und es war richtig cool, es war richtig schön. Aber du meinst im Fernsehen. Ja, okay, gut. Gut, okay, ja, dann erzähl, wie du die Oscars im Fernsehen gesehen hast. Nee, nee, ich wollte nur sagen, ich hab dir die Daumen zurück. Weil ich weiß nicht, ob ich es gesehen habe, ich war ja dieses Jahr nicht vor Ort, weil ich habe mir von einer relativ sicheren Quelle sagen lassen, dass wenn Oppenheimer nicht gewinnt, Christopher Nolan eine echte Atombombe im Saal detonieren wird. Und es ist jetzt letzten Endes, wir wissen nicht, ob es passiert wäre oder nicht, aber diese Quelle war extrem vertrauenswürdig. Mehr sage ich nicht, aber sie war sehr vertrauenswürdig. Okay? Von jemandem, der sich auskennt mit Atombomben. Okay. So. Und erst dachte ich, würde Christopher Nolan das wirklich machen? Aber auf der anderen Seite dachte ich mir, wer wenn nicht er? Er hat schon eine für den Film. Und ich meine, jeder weiss, Atombomben kommen immer in Paaren. Jeder weiss, wer eine, das ist so wie Schokomance, wer eine Atombombe zündet, kommt um die zweite nicht umhin. Nee, nee. Wer Hiroshima sagt, muss auch Nagasaki sein. Wenn du einmal anfängst, dann willst du mehr haben. Ja. Und deswegen finde ich, machen wir das an der Stelle in Deutschland gut.
Wir machen die Tipps wieder gar nicht jetzt gefangen. Gar nicht jetzt auf. Der erste Dominostein sieht immer so lecker aus, aber wer ihn umwirft, tja, am Ende ist die ganze Packung.
Das war jetzt misleading, weil Dominosteine selber eine Packung Essen sind.
Also ich war auf jeden Fall nicht vor Ort, ich hätte da sein können, ich war eingeladen, aber ich dachte mir, es ist zu gefährlich, wenn die Atombombe hochgeht, möchte ich mindestens ein Weltmehr zwischen mir und dieser Bombe haben und damit bin ich zu Hause geblieben. Christopher Donner hat halt vorher Jotabletten verteilt, ne? Das stimmt, das hat, ich meine, das ist ein beliebter Snack, das kann man auch mal so nebenbei, aber in dem Kontext fand ich es, also ich meine, das ist natürlich auch ein Gag, ne?
Bei Oppenheimer, in jedem Kino wurden ja Jotabletten verteilt. Das wär geil, wenn diese Minz oder Junior Minz oder so, diese amerikanischen Kinosnacks vor Oppenheimer ausgetauscht worden wären in so Jotabletten. Oh, durch Jotabletten. Und es steht drauf, Jotabletten in Klammern, kleiner Scherz, wir sind's, Smint. Leute, wir isst eine ganze Packung Smint. Wir hatten im Kinofilm einfach so. Ich nehme die 300-Gramm-Packung Fisherman's Friend. Me, a Cycle-Fans. Einfach Papi. Ich glaube, du musst den Raum nur betreten und du hast einen frischen Atem, selbst wenn du selber nichts gegessen hast. Aber ich schwöre damals. Ich nehme die Jumbo-Packungminz, bitte. Schatz, du kannst die nicht in den ersten fünf Minuten alle aufessen. Aber die sind... Mein Atem war noch nie so frisch. Dein Atem ist so frisch. Dein Atem ist so frisch und dann werden alle um dich herum so zu schrumpeln, so zusammen zu so Babys, weil es alles so frisch ist. Ja. Aber ich habe früher... Ich fand diese Tiktoks, Tiktaks, die orangenen Tiktaks, die waren
geil.
Hatten die einen Atemeffekt?
Das weiß ich nicht genau.
Oder waren die rein einfach nur genuss?
Ich fand die nämlich so geil und für mich haben die sich auch als Kind angefühlt wie
snackable Snacks.
Genau, für mich waren die immer der Cheatcode, dass du bei deinen Eltern sagst, ah Tiktak,
weil ich muss heute noch rumknutschen mit Bäcker in der Vorschule und die Eltern sagen, na na gut, wir wollen ja einen Gentleman auch erziehen. Und dann die Tic Tacs, aber du hintenrum. Ich habe erstens keine Freundin, zweitens, ich esse die einfach so, weil ich habe mir die roten genommen, Orangen. Ich glaube, die haben wirklich. Das weiß ich nicht genau. Aber was, also zum Beispiel Mentos. Mentos ist doch auch so ein Ding, was eigentlich immer beworben wurde als Erfrischung. Und dann kam plötzlich Kirschgeschmack, Lakritzgeschmack. Also verliert es irgendwann dieses Ding? Naja, du musst dir vorstellen, es ist ein Unternehmen. Die wollen Gewinne erzielen. Da geht es ja meistens nur um Geld. Es geht meistens nur um Gewinne. Es geht ja am Ende nur um Geld. Und deswegen meine ich, das Prinzip eines erfrischenden Snacks hat ja den Nachteil, wir machen unsere Laptops auf mute. Das haben wir vergessen in den Wochen. Und der Gewinner der aktuellen Laptop-Lotterie ist Philipp K. aus Bochum. Weißt du, was ich jetzt finde? Du hast richtig geschätzt, dass in der zwölften Minute die erste Mail reinkommt. Ja, Stefan ist ein, und du hast auch richtig getippt, dass Stefan die Mail kriegt, denn Stefan ist ein sehr
viel beschäftigter Mensch. Weißt du, was ich finde, wir sollten das wie im Unterricht damals machen, wir lesen die Mails jetzt immer, müssen die mal vorlesen. Okay, okay. Wir müssen Nachricht und oder Mail jetzt immer vorlesen. Ja, okay, das finde ich gut. Okay, was hast du bekommen, Stefan, wer stört, wer stört, wer stört die Aufnahme? ATU, kompletter Service, halber Preis und dann dieses Party.
Ah ja, diese Knalltüte.
Knalltüte. Knalltüte. Benutzen wir nicht. Jetzt wechseln und 50% sparen. Was ist ATU, was ist das? Das ist keine der Podcast-Sufo-Werbung. Es ist eine, ich muss, ich bin dazu, der Rechtsweg ist ausgeschlossen, ich muss diese Mail vorlesen. ATU sind Autoteile Unger, ist diese Autoteile ...
Gibt es in Unger ganz besonders gute Autoteile, oder was?
Ich habe das eigene Name, Herr Unger, von Wilhelm Unger gegründet.
Ach so, ich dachte in Ungingen, ach so.
In der Blog der Aller ...
Genau, also schreibt doch einfach selber ATU, vielleicht sind die was für euch.
Was ich sagen wollte, erfrischende Bonbons haben wir, wie du gerade gesagt hast, als Gag, fand ich super cool, wir spielen kurz zurück, du kannst doch nicht eine ganze Packung Smints im Kino essen. Jetzt wollen aber die Smint-Hersteller denken ja, na fuck, wir wollen ja mehr verkaufen, also Leute sollen noch ganz viel von uns bitte essen. Also meine These, Mentos hat erst dieses erfrischende Mintige rausgebracht, hat gemerkt, Leute teilen sich das ein. Leute lieben es, Leute lieben es, ist mega geil, aber sie teilen es sich ein. Sie essen zu wenig, sie essen zu wenig. Also haben sie gesagt, wir bringen jetzt noch folgende andere Geschmacksrichtungen raus, die man es netten kann. Tick-Tack ebenso sehr. Meine These, orangene Tick-Tacks waren so ein schnelles Heranführmittel. Ja, ja, die eher so wegsnackt, ne? Auch mit diesen nur wenigen Kalorien pro Ding. Ein Kalorie, genial. Du einfach weisst, dass es hast. Eine Kalorie pro Tic Tac. Meinst du, die tun sich auch so zusammen mit der Dönerindustrie und sagen so, hier, haut da mal extra Zwiebeln rein, ne? Ja, aber das reicht doch. Ich meine, so ein paar fünf Zwiebeln pro Döner-Tasche, das ist doch genug, oder?
Super.
Ah nee, komm, warte nochmal hier. Was ist denn da in der Soße drin, Knoblauch? Das finde ich gut. Unternehmen, die zusammenarbeiten, das ist unsere Verschwörungstheorie jetzt, Unternehmen, die zusammenarbeiten, von denen man es nicht gedacht hätte. Ja, die vielleicht sogar die ein, da steht einfach Herr Unger da hinten. Vorne hin natürlich Mustafa's Gemüse, Döner und Tick-Tack, aber dahinter steht einfach Horst Unger, dem einfach beide gehören und der schön einfach in beide Taschen greift, der auf beiden Seiten der Waage greift. Deutsche Oppenheimer, spannende Geschichte. Könnte man genauso, dann könnte man auch Smints und Döner verkaufen im Kinosaal währenddessen, könnte man die schön wechsnacken.
Da kann ja sein, dass sowohl die Zwiebellobby als auch die Tic Tac Lobby, die Erfrischungs-Snack Lobby, haben im Prinzip das gleiche Interesse. Sie wollen mehr verkaufen und wollen auch ein bisschen, nee, die Zwiebeln profitieren mehr davon. Die Zwiebeln profitieren nicht vom Verkauf von Smint.
Warum kann man keine Smints beim Dönerladen direkt kaufen? Weil es ist ja dann so diese klassische Situation, erstes Date oder so und dann sagt man, bitte ohne Zwiebeln und nicht die Knoblauch und bitte geben Sie mir die Ficky-Ficky-Sauce und dann ist es so ein bisschen unangenehm, so ah okay, ist es jetzt zu offensichtlich oder nicht.
Warum nicht einfach sagen, ich hätte gern Döner mit alles und dann aber noch schön Smint obendrauf. Oder man geht einfach den Kiosk nebenan und holt Smint, aber nee, ich finde es auch. Oh, das ist aber, das machst du beim ersten Date zu sagen, ah, ich brauche noch einen Smint. Damit ich einen guten Abend mache, um es hier rumzumachen. Ich habe noch in meinem Leben, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das überhaupt eine Marke ist. Ich habe, um mir deine, weil gerade gegen den Backenzähnen, da hängt ja dann oft noch mal schön Zaziki rum. Was will ich loswerden? Ich habe noch vor, mit dir rumzuknutschen und zu schäkern. Ich habe durchaus vor, meine Zunge bis hinten in Gaumennähe heranzupressen. Und da wäre es natürlich gut, wenn dann respektive meinerseitig natürlich die Backenzähne auch einigermassen in Schuss wären, sagen wir mal so. Ja? Dann gehe ich jetzt kurz was holen. Ja, haben wir uns? Gut, haben wir uns verstanden? Jesus Christ. Danke. Okay. Das wäre ja auch ein Sketch, also das offensichtliche Date, wo so alles ausgesprochen wird, so überoffensichtlich, so wo man alles nochmal ausspricht und dann am Ende? Lässt sich dann doch wie im echten Leben in Luft auf. Enttäuschung auf. Wacht man auf, schweissgebadet, die Katze mit grossen Augen neben einem, hat gerade schön die Krallen in Oberschenkel vergraben und man ist wieder in der echten Welt. Ich wusste gerade tatsächlich laut lachen im Zug. Es kommt jetzt eine Zuganekdote. In welchem Abteil warst du? Ich war in einem Einzelabteil, so einem Sechserabteil. Alleine? Nee, da waren noch andere Leute. Und war das ein Ruhrabteilabteil? Nee, normales Abteil. Normales Abteil, normale Loge. Willst du erst zuhören oder willst du erst alle Anschlussfragen stellen? Nee, ich brauche einfach ein paar Randinformationen. Vorschlussfragen. Damit ich diese Anekdote genießen kann, muss ich wissen, dass wir uns hier im rechtsfreien Raum bewegen, das hier alles in Ordnung ist, nicht im Ruheabteil, sonst kann ich an nichts anderes mehr denken. Das ist ja auch bei der Anekdote ganz, ganz irritiert. Und jetzt aber bin ich bereit, ich ziehe mir die Decke schön bis unter das Kinn, ich muckel mich ein, ich habe schon die Zähne geputzt und jetzt, ah, jetzt geht's. Die Schlafen mitzuzischen auf. Nee, es war sehr spannend für mich zu beobachten, diese Evolution des offensichtlich sehr jung klingenden Schaffners. Der Typ, der immer die Durchsage macht, ist wahrscheinlich der Hauptschaffner, Zugbegleiter, Zugführer in whatever. Aber nicht unbedingt der Fahrer, glaube ich. Ich habe schon mal gesehen, wie die an so einem funk ding da eingesprochen es ist ja wie so stewardess co-pilot pilot ja das ist dann so erster mart der commodore in manchen situationen aber dann doch die befehlsgewalt des anderen um es klarzumachen der left lieutenant hat dann diese durchsagen gemacht und man kennt das ja kennt das ja manchmal, in den meisten Fällen sind sie wahnsinnig, wir sind leichter-mässig unterwegs. Und er war so richtig energetisch und kommunikativ. Und er hat so gesagt, wir stehen das hier zusammen durch. Er hat so eine geile Mentalität gehabt, so eine super Hyper-Empathie. Man hat immer so etwas gesagt wie, ich habe eine gute und schlechte Nachricht für Sie,
aber eine schlechte Nachricht, wir kommen ja gleich in Münster an,
Leute. Und so, das war seine
Anschlüsse. Okay, ich gebe ihm noch zwei Wochen,
dann ist er gebrochen. Und ich habe auch gedacht,
und dann hat er gesagt, ich habe eine gute und schlechte Nachricht. Die gute Nachricht ist,
wir haben nur 20 Minuten
Verspätung und erreichen auch viele Anschlüsse.
Die schlechte Nachricht, der RE2
nach Lübeck, den verpassen wir jetzt
leider. Und das war seine, die Energie, das Energielevel. Und ich musste die ganze Zeit lachen, weil ich dachte, das kann man machen, wenn man in, weiß nicht, in der Schweiz bei der Bahn arbeitet, wo halt mal, da geht mal was schief. Und dann macht man das irgendwie, man steht zusammen durch und man hat so eine, weiß nicht, so eine weird, so eine Gruppenleiter-Energy. Genau, so wenn das Negative mal die Ausnahme ist. Ja, exakt. Jetzt heute mal ist leider die Baracke fünf abgebrannt, aber wir haben ja noch eine andere. Ja, Leute, ich habe eine richtig schlechte Nachricht für. Sie verpassen da den RE1, aber hier steht, ich soll Ihnen einen Zug empfehlen, der kommt eine Stunde später nur. Da müssen Sie gar nicht lange warten. Holen Sie sich einen Snack am Bahnhof. Na gutterlüh. Na guterlüh. Und ich habe gedacht, das kannst du überall machen, so wo alles läuft einigermassen, aber doch nicht. Und ich war sehr gespannt, wie es weitergeht. Ja, Kathut zwei Wochen später. Ja, hallo ihr Lieben, wir haben 19 schlechte Nachrichten und ja, okay, also die erste. Also wir verpassen. Ja und so war es nämlich nicht zwei Wochen später, sondern so war es innerhalb dieser dreieinhalb Stunden. Du hast die komplette Entwicklung miterlebt. Es war insane. Ich bin ja gerade, wir nehmen in Hamburg heute auf und ich bin von Köln nach Hamburg. Und auf dieser ganzen Fahrt hat sich diese Evolution, diese Metamorphose bereits abgespielt. Das ganze Leben quasi. Das war so spannend, weil er fing so an und ich dachte mir, das kann er unmöglich festhalten, weil wir haben schon 20 Minuten Verspätung. Meiner Erfahrung nach, wenn ein Zug 20 Minuten Verspätung hat, aber das können wir auch nochmal in Ruhe besprechen, aber ich glaube, dann wird der Zug nachteilig behandelt, weil er ist so eh verloren. Ja, ja, der ist verloren. Ich meine, Züge liegt pünktlich sind am Vorfahrt. Ja, wer Verspätung hat, kriegt noch mehr Verspätung, das ist ein Binnaturgesetz. Genau, don't sue us, weil wir das sagen, aber wir glauben dran. Wer einmal schön anfängt zu rollen, steht nicht mehr auf. Das ist so, wie wenn du so schlingerst, anfängst zu schlingern auf dem Motorrad oder so, es ist einfach verloren. Ja, für uns hat seine Motorradfahrze offensichtlich begonnen, spannend. Allerdings, kommen wir gleich noch dazu, Brum Brum. Ja, okay, oder wahrscheinlich sehen wir uns jetzt nie wieder, weil du einfach stirbst. Ja, das kann sein, ich hatte einen schon. Ja, aber, ja, schade, aber ich finde es schön, dass du dabei gewesen bist bei diesem jugendlichen Hoffnungswählen am Anfang. Am Anfang ging noch viel glatt und so und er hat sich dann immer rausgeredet und so. Und irgendwann war er dann schon so ein bisschen sauer, weil dann hat er die Nachricht bekommen, dass wir einen anderen ICE vorlassen müssen. Aus den, wie ich glaube, eben genannten Gründen. Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, ich habe jetzt leider eine schlechte Nachricht für Sie und keine gute mehr. Wir müssen, wir haben diesen ICE, warum auch immer, jetzt vorlassen müssen und Sie verpassen doch alle Züge, die ich ihn gerade noch genannt habe. Und man hat so gedacht, holy shit, dieses Gemüt ist nicht gemacht für die Deutsche Bahn.
Curb your enthusiasm ist wirklich... Du brauchst eigentlich den Grinch, du brauchst so einen Zyniker, jemand, der eh schon die Welt hasst, den brauchst du. So, ohne viele Überraschungen haben wir schon erstmal Verspätungen, stehen da und alle anderen kommen vor uns an. Alles klar, wir sehen uns im Bordbistro. Immerhin geht die Klimaanlage. Noch, ciao. So jemanden brauchst du eigentlich. Wenn jemanden brauchst du und du kannst nicht so ein, der war zu sensibel, der war zu empathisch, er war zu energetisch, das hat nicht gepasst. Und ich fand das so fehl am Platz, gecastet in dieser Rolle des Lebens, ich fand das sehr fantastisch. Und dann auch natürlich, ne. Das ist auch eine schöne Kategorie, Fehlbesetzungen im echten Leben. Einfach wenn der Charakter einfach nicht zum Job passt. Misscast. Ja ist nicht schlecht, er ist nur in der falschen Rolle. Man müsste den nehmen und dann irgendjemand anderen, der Zyniker ist, irgendwie so Callcenter-Zyniker oder so, und die müsste man dann austauschen. Vielleicht wäre das auch ein Fernsehprogramm, ich denke da bei der Moderation an ... Ähm, ähm, Guido. Naja, ich würde eigentlich, Guido kann's denken,
aber ich hab den schon lange nicht mehr
gesehen. Ich auch nicht. Irgendwie,
wo ist, weiss ich gar nicht, gibt's den noch?
Ich hab den auch nicht mehr gesehen, ich glaub, da gehen so
Gerüchte rum, aber die wollen wir jetzt nicht.
Sonja Ziedlow. Ja, Sonja Ziedlow.
So, zum Beispiel, so, und die, das ist so ein bisschen
wie Frauentausch, Jobtausch. Jobtausch.
Hast du keinen Bock mehr auf deinen Job?
Bewirb dich bei Sonja. Sonjas Jobkarussell. Ich finde gut, das ist dann die Sendung in Frauentausch, Jobtausch. Hast du keinen Bock mehr auf deinen Job? Bewirb dich bei Sonja. Sonjas Jobkarussell. Ich finde gut, dass es dann die Sendungen Frauentausch und Jobtausch gibt. Als wären das Dinge, es ist halt auf eine Art eine, weiß ich nicht, ein Kommentar. Ja, worauf auch immer weiß man nicht, man interpretiert dir das. Und dann hast du hundert Leute, die ihren Job hassen und dann Sonja setzt sich hin, die hat dann so einen grossen Stapel Papiere, setzt sich an den Schreibtisch und setzt dann die Brille auf. Da willst du anfangen? Du willst quasi von der Autofahrt von Sonja Ziedlow zum Studio. Also Sonja Ziedlow zieht sich noch die Schuhe an, Jacke an, habe ich alles dabei, Schlüssel, Tür zu. Wo ist mein Auto? Florentin, du sollst später anfangen, wenn du eine Show pitchst. aber das will ich ja sehen. Ich finde, am Ende der ersten Staffel sollte es losgehen. Ich will wissen, wie es losgeht. Und dann will ich der Sonja Ziedler an ihrem Schreibtisch sitzen mit ganz vielen Zetteln und so. Was haben wir hier? Aha, guck mal, hier ist zum Beispiel ein Landwirt, der keine Tiere mag. Der hat hundert Kühe und mag die nicht und er findet die blöd und ist ein kollegiales Dissens. Blöd! Genau, ist ein distanziertes Verhältnis. Und hier haben wir zum Beispiel jemanden, der arbeitet irgendwie bei der Bahn und der hätte gern ein Tier. Und dann kommen die zusammen und dann besucht Sonja den einen erstmal, dann holt sich einen Döner, Mittagspause vielleicht, sowas in der Richtung. Guckt mal, ähm, so, das war Bauer Ludwigsen und, ähm, Herr Ludwigsen, wo gibt's denn hier in der Nähe, wo kann man hier was essen? Jetzt haben wir ja Mittag. Gibt's hier irgendwo in der Nähe was, was Schönes, wo man mal was essen kann? Ein Imbiss oder so, einfach so ein Currywurst oder sowas in der Richtung?
Gar nicht, also wo gehen Sie denn hin, wenn Sie mal außer Haus? Oh, ihr ist bei mir. Oh, ihr ist bei mir. Aha, und? Stell mir bitte keine Anfassung. Ich habe hier einen. Okay, Stefan, wir kennen uns so lange. Dieses Zeichen verstehe ich mittlerweile schon gut. Ich nehme keine Anschlussfrage mehr. Ich bin bayerisch falsch abgewogen. Denn Sonja setzt sich wieder in ihr Auto. Naja. Ah, sie steigt wieder aus. Okay. Sie steigt auch nochmal aus. Der Tonmann ist dran geblieben. Ja? Möchten Sie noch was sagen? Naja, er ist bei mir. Alles klar. Gut, dann würden wir uns melden, sobald wir mehr wissen. Saupreis. Und ja, dann tschüss. Das war Bauer Ludwigsen. Jetzt schauen wir mal in den nächsten Ort, ob wir da was zu essen finden. Und dann Mittagspause, erstmal gucken mit den Leuten da im Ort. Warum diese Mittagspause? Was ist die Show? Sonja muss was essen. Ja, natürlich muss Sonja was essen, aber das ist ja eher so Back-Catalog, das ist ja so Back-Office-Dram. Du kannst sie den ganzen Tag durcharbeiten. Nein, das soll sie auch nicht. Du musst nur nicht überall die Kamera draufhalten. Wir kriegen die Tapes von ihrer Show und es ist nur Sonja Ziedler privat. Nein, nein, nein, die Dispo ist ja neun bis zwölf Location A, Bauernhof, Mittagessen und dann? Dann muss nämlich der Typ, der diese furchtbare Show erfunden hat, macht eigentlich Dokumentationen über Sonja Ziedler. Yes, das ist geil. Und genau die ganze die Dokumentation über Sonja Zieselow. Wir waren bei Bauer Ludwigsen und nächster Halt ist die Sat.1-Redaktion, wo ich mal mit der Britta sprechen werde.
Sie ist Redakteurin bei dieser Sendung und macht offensichtlich keinen guten Job.
Ja, ich würde gern was mit Tieren machen, so, und dann kommen die zusammen.
Und dann irgendwann sitzt Bauer Ludwigsen in der Regie und macht dann immer die Überblende oder so. Und da haben wir gerade gemerkt, er ist brillanterin. Er wäre brillant. Das haben wir gemerkt. Es ist eine gute Sendung. Sonja, ruf uns an und falls du uns hörst und anrufst, mach die Kamera an. Wir haben jetzt noch kein Kamerateam bei dir. Sonja, ziehtlos zu sagen, dass sie sich filmen soll. Aber dann können wir direkt da ansitzen bei der Sendung. Das ist Ein rechtsfreier Raum? Nee, wie war das? Der Rechtsweg ist... Muss man den irgendwann wieder auflösen? Also ist es so wie... Die Schranke zum Rechtsweg geht wieder auf. Dass man sagt, Leute, übrigens, der Rechtsweg ist ab jetzt wieder offen. So, ab jetzt geht's weiter. Klage, klage, klage, klage, klage. Und jetzt wieder zu. Okay, aber die vier Klagen, um die müssen wir uns kümmern. Aber er ist das einmal zu für immer.
Jetzt zieh doch noch ein bisschen stärker am Kabel. Kurz noch ein paar aufnahmetechnische Sachen. Ich habe Angst, dass du dein Kabel rausziehst gleich. Eine reelle Angst. Dann habe ich eine andere reale Angst. Du haust oft auf den Tisch. Jetzt kriege ich wieder Anschiss von Herrn Tietze. Nee, ich meine nur, jetzt kriege ich wieder Anschiss. Nee, weil dann krieg ich ja Anschiss von den Hörerinnen und Hörern, die sagen, ihr haut die ganze Zeit auf den Tisch, die Kameras wackeln. Ich haue auf den Tisch. Ich haue auf den Tisch. Heute haue ich mal auf den Tisch in der Folge. Das sollten die Leute ruhig hören, dass ich mir das nicht mehr lange gefallen lasse von dir. Ja, dass ich mir das nicht lange gefallen lasse. Nee, ist ja völlig okay. Stefan Tietze. Du hast die Oscars gesehen. Ich hab die Oscars gesehen live zum ersten Mal. Ach so, das war das erste Mal. Ach so. Ich wollte auch nur sagen, dass ich Sandra Hüller die Daumen gedrückt habe, die dann ja auch indirekt gewonnen hat für The Zone of Interest. Mehr wollte ich gar nicht sagen. Ich habe mir früher jedes Jahr die Oscars angeschaut, auch immer mit Live Oscars, Rocket Beans und so. Und ich erinnere mich noch genau, dass ich jedes Mal zur Oscar-Verleihung mir so eine Fünferpackung Kit-Kat gekauft habe.
Fünf Kit-Kats und wirklich, ich war so beeindruckt von diesem Stapel und ich habe die am Anfang des Abends alle ausgepackt und alle schon so übereinander gelegt. Also die sind ja in der Packung so übereinander, die sind Tafeln, ich rede jetzt nicht von Chunky, ich rede jetzt von diesen Tafeln-Kit-Kat-Tagen. Und während die anderen beeindruckt waren von, ah, Will Smith hat jemand auf der Bühne geschlagen, ah, krass, Leonard DiCaprio hat immer noch keinen Oscar bekommen, warst du primär beeindruckt über die Kit-Kats, die übereinander waren? Fünf mal vier. Ich hatte zwanzig Kit-Kat-Rippen. Die lagen alle so übereinander, wie so ein Brennholzstapel.
Und irgendwann habe ich auch angefangen, die einzeln abzubrechen und die dann noch mal zu stapeln, wie so ein Leuchtfeuer
und dann habe ich die innerhalb von
glaube ich zwölf Minuten einfach komplett
mir reingestopft, einfach
rein
ja und dann bin ich irgendwann eingeschlafen.
Seelig eingeschlafen. Bin ich irgendwann eingeschlafen,
noch bevor ein Film gewonnen habe,
dann habe ich am nächsten Tag auf Wikipedia nachgeguckt, wer gewonnen hat.
Ich habe so wenig Disziplin, dass ich sobald ich mir Süssigkeiten kaufe und die bei mir habe, sind die alle am gleichen Abend noch alles weg. Muss sein. Es geht bei mir nicht um Hunger, es geht nur noch um Lust am Essen und aufessen. Und das Schlimmste, was mir passieren kann, und auch wenn es eine sehr, sehr nette Geste ist und ich mich immer freue, das Schlimmste, was passieren kann, sind so Fan-Einsendungen, Fressboxen. Das ist wirklich, ich kriege die Packung schon und ich weiss, oh oh, weil das ist dann so, oft wenn Leute dann so auch hier bei Rocket Beans oder so Süßigkeiten einschicken, dann schicken die ja nicht nur so eine Packung in Colorado ein, weil die denken, okay, jetzt mache ich mal, jetzt stelle ich mal so ein Paket zusammen und dann einfach viel zu viel Zeug. Und ich weiss so, ich werde nicht glücklich, bis das alles aufgegessen ist und muss dann echt gucken, wie es läuft. Jetzt kriegst du so Abnehmpillen oder so unsexy Geschenke. Also das ist immer nett und klar, das ist völlig in Ordnung und so, aber es ist immer schon mal schwierig, wenn man so ein bisschen dieses Overeater-Ding hat, dass man dann denkt, okay, das muss alles noch weg heute. Da kam mir inzwischen in den Zeilen zwei verschiedene Botschaften raus. Erstens, ich bin fett. Erstens, ich will mehr, auch ein bisschen kam raus, finde ich. Ich will mehr. Leute schicken, die Durchschnittseinsendung, das kam mir gerade so ein bisschen durch, ist nicht nur eine Colorado-Verpackung, sondern... Hör auf jetzt, Stefan, Quatsch. Da kam er jetzt ein bisschen mit, so als ob du das verlangst. Also nur damit ihr da draußen wisst, Florentin, wenn er was geschenkt bekommt, und er kriegt offensichtlich viel geschenkt an Süßigkeiten-Kram, kriegt er mindestens so drei, von wie viel reden will, Colorado? Nein, also es geht los bei 900 Gramm. Es geht ... Insgesamt, es geht los bei 900 Gramm und nach oben ist echt nichts, es gibt kein Limit. Aber bei denen weisst du auch die Namen. Also du weisst das untere Ende, da kennst du die Namen. Absolut, absolut. Ich merke mir immer die untersten fünf und die können natürlich abgelöst werden, wenn sie noch mal einschicken und mehr einschicken. Aber nee, ich verteile das ja auch immer nett an Kollegen und so, damit das nicht behandelt. Nee,, weil ich habe ja keine Disziplin. Sobald ich was kaufe und es können auch so, keine Ahnung, es kommen Leute rum und man will noch Snacks besorgen, weil ich nie was da habe, besorgt man noch was und dann ist es weg, ist alles weg. Ich habe gar keine Disziplin, sobald da was rumliegt, esse ich das. Ich weiß nicht genau, was das bei mir aussagt, wahrscheinlich wahnsinnig geringe Disziplin. Vor allem, du hast keine Geschwister, ne, also ich dachte bei mir immer so, das ist vielleicht so ein geschwisterlicher Futterneid irgendwie so, dass man dann so schnell alles essen muss, weil die Brüder sonst und ich habe auch oft meinen Brüdern Sachen weggegessen und hat dann auch ein schlechtes Gewissen und so und also da ist viel, glaube ich, auch noch vergraben, was das angeht, aber spannend ist schon schwierig Aber bei dir muss es ja dann wirklich was anderes sein. Wobei, ich habe auch das Gefühl, man kann solche Sachen immer in beide Richtungen argumentieren. Ja, klar. Also entweder man hat Futterneid, weil man Geschwister hat und deswegen schnell sein muss und mehr haben will, oder du hast Futterneid, weil du Einzelkind bist, weil du gewohnt bist, immer alles zu haben, willst du nichts abgeben. Also man kann aber auch klar so angenehm aus argumentieren, weil man immer denkt, dass man eh mal alles bekommt, teilt man gerne. Man kann aber auch argumentieren, weil du Brüder hast, bist du gewohnt, Dinge abzugeben. Ich finde, man kann, viele Sachen, die in der Kinder passiert sind, sind in beide Extreme, aber nichts dazwischen. Aber in beide Extreme verargumentierbar. Deswegen immer super schwer, wenn es gewisse Sachen nur in grossen Packungen gibt, irgendwie so Kinderpingui. Oder jetzt zum Beispiel habe ich tatsächlich einen Supermarkt bei mir in der Nähe gefunden, der hat Paradiso. Paradiso, ja nicht ein gängiges Kühlfrucht, nicht Frucht, aber Milchschnitte, Pinguiparadiso. Das kannte ich früher immer nur aus Italien, aber ist jetzt tatsächlich manchmal verfügbar. Und ich habe jetzt einen Dealer, ich habe jetzt einen Ort des Vertrauens, wo ich das kriege, schöne Viererpackung. Und das ist einfach nur Ei mit Zucker, mit Ei mit Zucker, mit Puderzucker drauf. Es schmeckt nicht wirklich nach was. Es ist so, wie wenn man so, du machst machst jetzt einen Kuchen, aber es ist kein Kirschkuchen, sondern du machst Mehl, Zucker, Eier, Milch, so nur die Standardsachen. Das ist wie wenn du nur einen Pizzateig isst. Isst du da eine Pizza? Also isst du einen Kuchen, wenn du nur den Basic-Teig isst? Eigentlich nicht. Christina Tosi, die habe ich mal nachgekocht mit diesem Crack Pie. Da gab es ja auch so eine Chefstable-Folge drüber, über diese Dessertköchin, wo wir jetzt auch habe ich was mitgebracht für uns beide, als wir in New York waren, bin ich da kurz vorbeigelaufen. Die hat diesen berühmten Crack Pie gemacht und die Idee, der heisst Crack, weil alle nicht aufhören konnten, davon zu naschen. Sie hat für so ein Stern so ein sternen restaurant gearbeitet und dann gibt es halt so events wo halt alle aus dem team was mitbringen und kochen und sie hat als nachtisch köchin dann halt kuchen gemacht übrigens eine furchtbare vorstellung dass du in einem rahmen rahmen wo alle kochen und selbst kochen für alle kochen muss holy. Es ist ja schon schlimm, wenn man in einer Firma was mitbringen muss oder sowas, wo man denkt, wahrscheinlich können Leute besser kochen als ich und besser backen. Vor allem, da hast du keine Chance, irgendwie so einen tiefkühl Käsekuchen. Nein, da musst du deinen A-Game, fucking A-Game bringen. Da hat sie nämlich genau, was du gerade beschrieben hast, gemacht.
Einen Kuchen, der eigentlich nur aus diesen Hauptzutaten besteht.
Butter, Ei, Mehl, gut, Haferflocken noch, aber das war dann eher Teil dieses Crunchy-Ramens,
wahnsinnig viel Zucker, wahnsinnig viel Butter und mehr ist da nicht drin.
Ich sag mal so.
Und es war genial. Es schmeckt einfach nach dem, was dann in Snickers drin ist, wo dann noch Erdnüsse draufkamen. Ja, genau. Ja, so die Basics einfach. Die Basics. Die sich durchsetzen, die sich bei jedem gucken, wiederholen. Ich finde oft so, wenn ich einen guten Film gesehen habe, dann sage ich jemandem, hey, schau dir den guten Film an. Und dann sagt die Person, worum geht's in dem Film? Und dann sage ich, eigentlich um nichts. Das sind oft ja die besten Filme, wo man sagt, eigentlich geht's um nichts. Das ist einfach nur Florentins Lingo für, ich hab den ganzen Plot vergessen. Oder ich war zu sehr, weil er Kit Katz fixiert. Es gibt ja manche Filme, wo man sagt, ein Meteorit schlägt auf die Erde ein und schlägt die Erde in zwei Teile und dann gibt's die Nordhemisphären Menschen und die Südhemisphären Menschen. Und die bekriegen sich um Ressourcen. Ehrlich gesagt, I love this! Weil die Erzphären drehen sich direkt um, sodass sie sich gegenseitig sehen können und drehen sich immer so gegenseitig. Und dann geht aber auf einer Seite geht dann das Essen aus und dann müssen die auf die andere Seite und dann müssen die so Seile werfen und so. Darum geht's in dem Film.
Es kann nur eines überleben von uns.
Genau. Und da kann man sagen, darum geht's in dem Film.
Und wer spielt da mit? Völlig egal.
Aber wie lustig wär's, wenn der Film so gut wär, dieser Trashy-Film, den wir gerade beschrieben haben, ist so gut, dass wenn jemand danach dich fragt, worum geht's in dem Film, sagst du, eigentlich um nichts.
Eigentlich um nichts.
Und dann guckst du in diesen Film, wo ein Meteorite auf die Erde ist. Ich stelle mir auch so ein ganz, so ein Pizzameteorit vor, der einfach so die Welt so. Worin ging es um in Roland Emmerichs Mooncrashing? Darum geht's eigentlich nicht. Eigentlich war es eine Vater-Sohn-Geschichte. Eigentlich war es eine Geschichte zwischen zwei Menschen, die aber auch nicht hätte stattfinden können. Also es war ... Worin ging's in The Day After Tomorrow? Lass mich überlegen. Eigentlich ist eine ... Es geht um Verlangen und Wollen. Es geht eigentlich ums Menschsein. Es geht eigentlich ums Menschsein. Im Grunde geht's darum, was es heisst, Mensch zu sein. Eigentlich dieser Angriff der Killer-Zombies, worum ging es da nochmal? Im Prinzip geht es hier darum, Fremdwirkung, Außenwirkung. Wie will man selbst sein und will man sich nicht verstellen für andere? Bei Jurassic Park 3. Ja, im Kern geht es darum, sei du selbst, kämpf für dich selbst und hör auf dein Herz. Und genauso, glaube ich, ist das Essen am besten, bei dem man nicht sagen kann, wonach es schmeckt. Wenn du sagst, wonach schmeckt der Kuchen, worum geht es bei dem Kuchen und du sagst, eigentlich um nichts. Es geht nicht um den Kuchen, sondern mit wem du den isstimmeln ist. Oder sowas. Ja. So, und jetzt stopfe ich mir Paradiso rein den ganzen Tag. Vier Stück pro Packung müssen alle gegessen werden. Und leider habe ich mir jetzt auch bei diesem Supermarkt auch wieder die Kuchentheke verbrannt. Weil, weil ich habe das Gefühl, man kriegt keinen normalen Käsekuchen mehr, oder?
Jerry Seinfeld, ich kann dir nicht mehr folgen.
Jerry Seinfeld stellt Text auf.
Oder kennt ihr das nicht auch?
Es gibt keinen klassischen Käsekuchen mehr, oder?
Da ist ein Cheesecake, da ist ein Cheesecake, wo ist der normal Cheesecake?
Da war es normal Cheesecake, und dann war es nicht.
Da war Cheesecake, und da war es Cherry Cheesecake, und jetzt war es 100 Cheesecakes, und es war ein Cheesecake! There was no more cheesecake and then there was a cheesecake and there was a chili cheesecake and now there are a hundred cheesecakes and there's so much cheesecake! Und deswegen tatsächlich, ich weiss nicht, ob das bei dieser Bäckerei im Speziellen ist, es gibt immer so Käsekuchen, wo dann noch so Mandarinen drin sind oder irgendwie Kirschen oder irgendwie Zeug. Das Remouladenphänomen, wie ich es nenne, auf normalen Schnittbrötchen findet man nämlich nur noch Remoulade. Die Butter ist langsam weg.
Die Butter wurde rausremouladisiert und jetzt ist das Problem oft mit den Beschilderungen, stimmt es nicht, wie heissen die Dinger, die da liegen, es ist super nervig. Ganz ehrlich, ich finde das süss, weil wenn du so viel Zeit in diesen Craft-Kuchen machen steckst und dann hast du da so ältere Mitarbeiter, die dann irgendwie noch so sich verwirklichen an dieser Konditoreimeisterei, die haben dann keine Zeit, auf die Schilder da vorne zu achten. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Eine Bäckerei, die die Schilder vorne alle richtig hat, die haben Dreck am Stecken. Ne, da ist auch wirklich so ein legendärer Maestro in der Küche, der sagt, Giuseppe, Giuseppe, die Leute wissen gar nicht, was sie kaufen sollen, es stehen irgendwo Schilder dann. Wer meine Kunst nicht zu schätzen weiss, hat sie auch nicht verdient.
Ja, wir sind wieder ... Okay, und hier sind noch die Ur-Uhrkraft-Körnchen oder irgendwie so Bullshit.
Und deswegen, Kuchen sagt ich jetzt ... Ich war in der Theke und hab gesagt, ich will einfach ...
Was ist das für eine Halte? Kuchen sagt ich jetzt, ich war in der Theke und hab gesagt, ich will einfach ...
Was ist das für eine Haltung? Was ist das für eine Haltung?
Als das seit zwei Stunden dieser Stunde gewesen, ich will doch einfach mal einen Käsekuchen.
Ich will einfach nur einen Käsekuchen, bitte, junge Dame.
Ich hab einfach so, ich kapituliere, das kennen wahrscheinlich Kellner gut, die so an den Tisch kommen und jemand sitzt mit so einem völlig leeren Gesicht vor der Karte, wo so in ganz klein gedruckt hunderte Gerichte stehen, mit so einem, ich will einfach satt sein jetzt. So, und mit so einer ähnlichen Miene stand ich dann auch dran und war einfach so, ich möchte hier nicht das Spiel spielen, bitte, ich möchte nur einen Käsekuchen.
Ich sagte, ja, ich hätte gern irgendeinen Käsekuchen. Haben Sie denn sowas wie Käsekuchen, irgendeinen Käsekuchen? Und dann meint sie, ah ja, wir haben hier den Cheesecake mit Kirschen. Oh mein Gott. Und ich so, ah ja, okay, dann nehme ich den Käsekuchen. Und sie so, sie wollen den Cheesecake. Ach so, ein Sprachproblem. Und ich so, ja gut, dann nehme ich den Käsebuchen und sie so sie wollen den Cheesecake ach so ein Sprachproblem und ich und ich so ja gut dann nehme ich den Cheesecake I'm sorry und bis heute weiss ich gar nicht genau warum ich das gesagt habe war es mein Gehirn das einfach geswitcht ist auf die Englander auf den engländischen Sprachen einfach geswitcht ist oder war es so ein Gag, ein sassy Gag, oh thank you, ja dann nehme ich ja den Cheesecake, thank you my darling, thank you my darling, thank you goodbye, no thanks, so, weiss ich nicht und sie mit so einem, ah okay, sassy comment, so, musste das jetzt sein, und dann hatte ich diesen Kuchen in der Hand und bin rausgegangen und dachte mir, was ist hier gerade passiert? Ich wollte doch nur einen Kuchen kaufen.
Ich wollte doch nur einen Kuchen essen. Ich schaute hinunter in meine Rechte und sah diesen Kuchen, als er langsam in mein Gesichtsloch gefahren ist, aber ich konnte ihn nicht genießen. Du merkst denn daran, dass es nämlich nicht darum geht, um den Kuchen an sich, sondern das ganze Erlebnis aus diesem Kuchenkauf, ich gönne mir jetzt mal was. Aber du standst ja mit so einer
Ich will einfach nur
Cheesecake-Haltung schon in der Schlange. Da kann es ja nichts werden, Pyrrothin. Du musst dahinter und sagen, ich will mir jetzt was gönnen. Es stimmt schon, es muss von Anfang an funktionieren. Ich glaube, wenn was beim Einkauf schon schlecht läuft, dann schmeckt es auch nicht richtig. Weil es muss von Anfang an passen. Ein anderes Beispiel dafür für dieses Ding, der Kontext macht es aus. Ich finde, ich höre manchmal Songs, die kann, glaube ich, niemand nachvollziehen, warum ich die höre. Und ich höre die nur, weil ich die aus einem Film mit einer Szene verbinde oder mit dem unmittelbaren Gefühl, was ich hatte, als ich es zum ersten Mal gehört habe. Ja. Und es ist nicht per se ein guter Song. Da würden Leute sagen, warum hörst du das denn? Wir waren doch mal weiter mit dir. Wir hatten das ja schon. Das Thema hatten wir ja schon. Wir hatten doch schon mal über das Digimon-Album gesprochen. Genau, okay, erst da. Aber ich mag so gern. Aber ich mag so gern. Ich habe letztens, also ich glaube, ich bin sehr beeinflussbar für Werbung und Eindrücke.
Ich glaube, ich auch.
Aber auf eine merkwürdige Art, weil, klar, kaufe ich Sachen wegen Werbung, aber manchmal kaufe ich auch Sachen einfach, weil ich es irgendwo sehe. So, und dann einfach war zum Beispiel, ich habe wieder die Quiz-Sendung gesehen, über die wir gesprochen haben, Only Connect. Only Connect. Only Connect. Ich bin so tief in der Lore jetzt drin. Und super Quiz-Sendung, könnt ihr euch gerne anschauen auf YouTube, sehr extrem schwer, aber die einfachste Kategorie ist noch die letzte mit den Konsonanten, wo es Wörter gibt, wo man nur die Konsonanten sieht und dann muss man sagen, was das eigentliche Wort war. Was findest du die härteste? Nee, die leichteste, die leichteste. Das ist das so ein bisschen, das ist die Gummiband-Kategorie, wo man am Ende noch Punkte sammeln kann, damit es spannend ist. Jede Folge ist so eine halbe Stunde lang, man beantwortet keine Frage als Zuschauer richtig, die während fast alle Fragen beantwortet werden von den Kandidaten. Man denkt, holy shit, wie kann ich leben auf diesem Planeten? Und dann kommt die letzte Runde und man hat so drei richtig, schneller, vielleicht manchmal sogar als die Kandidaten und denkt, holy shit, I'm the genius, ich gucke noch neun Folgen davon. So funktioniert psychologisch diese Sendung. Genau, aber du weisst, am Ende kriege ich auf jeden Fall noch mal was mit. Das ist wie so ein Kindergeburtstag, wo du hast beim Topfschlagen verloren, du hast beim Esel Schwanz anstecken verloren, du wurdest beim Suchen nicht gefunden, du hast beim Fangen jemanden gefangen, aber am Ende kriegst du noch so einen Mini-Snickers auf dem Weg. Ein Goodie-Bag.
Auf ein Goodie-Bag, darauf kannst du dich verlassen.
So, und dann war die Kategorie, glaube ich, ich weiss nicht mehr genau, was die Kategorie war, exotische Früchte, glaube ich, oder sowas in der Richtung.
Und wie gesagt, man kriegt immer nur die Konsonanten und muss dann das Wort nennen.
Und die Konsonanten waren B, B, B.
Und dann, nach dem ersten Mal, Exotische Frucht, Basketball, ich wusste es nicht, aber es wurde aufgelöst zu Baobab.
Ah, Baobab.
Und dann habe ich, hat man schon mal gehört, Exotische Frucht, Baobab. Und dann habe ich das mal recherchiert und gegoogelt und am Ende habe ich mir eine Packung Baobab-Pulver gekauft. Einfach nur, weil ich das Wort witzig finde. Affenbrotbäume. Es ist ein Affenbrotbaum und am Ende habe ich mir einfach eine Packung von Baobab-Pulver bestellt, einfach weil es so viel Spaß macht, Baobab zu sagen. Und seitdem wache ich jeden Morgen auf und sage, jetzt erst mal Baobab. Und alles, was ... Heute ist ein Baobab-Tag. Warum war mein Tag heute so gut? Heute war ein Baobab-Tag. Bitte mehr Baobab. Und alles, was diese Frucht richtig gemacht hat, war ihr witziger Name. So ist also nichts anderes daran, aber ich war so fasziniert von diesem
Namen und am Ende war der Name einfach die
gesamte Werbung und seitdem habe ich Baobab-Pulver
und es wurde beschrieben, sondern ja, wie
schmeckt Baobab-Pulver, wie hieß
Baobab generell? Ja, du sagst das Wort einfach
wahnsinnig gerne.
Der eine, ja, Baobab schmeckt so ein bisschen
säuerlich, der andere meint, ja, Baobab ist
so ein bisschen leicht karamellig.
Da dachte ich mir, interessant, hat mir das Baobab-Pulver
bestellt. Ja, sag Pulver. Und
das Baobab-Pulver ist
Vielen Dank. Säuerlich, der andere meint, ja, Baobab ist so ein bisschen leicht karamellig. Da dachte ich mir, interessant, hat mir das Baobab-Pulver bestellt.
Ja, sag Pulver.
Und das Baobab-Pulver ist, das kann man in Joghurt mischen, dann wird es Baobab-Pulver oder man kann es in Wasser mischen, dann wird es Baobab-Wasser oder so.
Und es wird gehandelt als ein Superfood.
Wie zum Beispiel.
Einfach, es ist halt eine Frucht von weit weg. Ja. Also Superfood. Chiasamen. Genau, ist ein Superfood. Ja, ja. Aber niemand weiss, aber es ist so, es ist super, super. Lass die Topfoods gründen. Ja. Topfoods. Oder halt Flopfood. Superfood und Topfood. Genau, Flopfoods, Frupps, Fruitloops. Die Flopfoods, Fruitloops. Die am schlechtesten Fruitloops. FlopproFrops, Frop-Loops. Und dann versprechen wir uns bei unserer allerersten Pressekonferenz, weil wir Fruit Loops zum Flop-Fruit gemacht haben. Und das ist hinter der Bühne. Und hier ist Stefan Tietze, CEO von Flop-Fruits. Was du sagen? Hier ist Stefan Tietze, der CEO von Flopfruits. Foods. Entschuldigung, hier ist Stefan Tietze, der CEO von Flopfruits. Ich lege dir so zu. Ich bin sichtlich nervös. Herzlich willkommen zur ersten Flopfruits-Konferenz. Und ich merke, es läuft gut. Die Musik setzt ein und ich gucke so hinter dir und will zeigen uns zu Daumen zu.
Ja, wir haben unseren ersten Flopfood gefunden und es ist Fruit Loops. Fruit Loops ist unser erstes Flopfood. Ja, Ja! Moneyball-eske, we did it, we fucking did it! Zeitlupe, so Wasser ins Gesicht, du wirst so mit Wasser überströmen wie so ein Trainer.
Zeitlupe.
Fruit Loops sind unser erstes Flufffood.
Wo wir gerade lange über Snacks reden und generell immer schon über Snacks gesprochen haben. Ja, ich weiß. Baobab ist ein Superfood. Aber du redest sehr gerne über Snacks und ich wollte kurz einen Podcast empfehlen von zwei guten Freunden und Arbeitskollegen. Die haben jetzt einen Snack-Podcast, Snackable, nee, sorry, Snacks Education. Mein Vorschlag war Snackable.
Okay, und das drückst du jetzt, hast du machst einen eigenen Konkurrenz-Podcast auf? Okay, nein, Snacks Education von Kevin und Jules. Snacks Education. Der Name, der dir nicht gefällt, wie war der nochmal? Der mir gefällt? Der dir nicht gefällt, den sie genommen haben? Snacks Education. Snacks Education. Ah, ich verstehe. Ich finde, es gibt gute Namen, aber es ist kein schlechter Name. Hört mal rein, es ist ein ganz toller Podcast. Jules und Kevin reden über Funfacts zu Snacks. Moment, der Jules? Du kennst beide. Ah, okay. Du kennst beide. Und die machen jetzt diesen Podcast. Könnt wöchentlich reinhören und euch educaten lassen über Snacks. Wir hören mal kurz rein. Ja, hi Kevin, ähm, hast du, also ich hab mir heute mal ein Superfood, baubub, baub, baub, ach nee, das waren wir. Und jetzt ist du die ganze Zeit. Komplette Podcast mit Essen im Mund, einfach komplett. Und warum hast du komplett eingefallene Haut und so Ätz, Wegezende, Ätzende, Ätzende, Es ist Superfood! Hautlappen, die dir von der Fresse hängen. Es ist super! Mir geht's super! Deine Augen sind gelb, Florentin. Okay, du zerfällst, du hustest, deine Augen sind gelb, du hast Lieder wie Schlangen, die von rechts und links kommen. Du fragst mich wahrscheinlich am Ende, wie schmeckt Baobab. N. Und ich hab's da. Ah! Das finde ich cool. Ich habe leider einen Fehler gemacht. Das ist eine wiederverschliessbare Packung, aber ich habe es oben aufgeschnitten. Also es ist immer offen. Und es hieß erst säuerlich. Und du kannst es mal kurz beschreiben für alle, die jetzt überlegen. Ich habe wenig Wasser. Kannst du was da reinmachen? Du kannst einfach mal riechen. Ich würde auch probieren.
Kannst du mal riechen wie Bauernbappulver.
Man muss es jetzt so ASMR.
Achtung, für den Werbeeffekt nicht umdrehen.
Man muss es so ASMR-mäßig so richtig.
Ja gut, das ist die Packung.
Das könnte jetzt jede Packung sein, ne?
Ich habe nicht gerochen, ich habe noch ein Mikrofon gerochen, um die.
Okay, wie riecht das Mikrofon? Zum Vergleich einfach, damit wir einen Vergleich haben.
Als hätten schon ganz viele Menschen reingesprochen.
Ja, Pulver. Es riecht wie Pulver.
Es riecht wie Pulver.
Es riecht wie die, wenn du dir vorstellen müsstest, du riechst an einem Pulver und niemand spezifiziert genau was für ein Pulver.
Okay, aber guck mal, deswegen sage ich die Basics.
Bisschen sauer.
Das ist Basic-Pulver.
Kannst du mir das mal bitte ein bisschen da reinfüllen jetzt, ohne dass wir jetzt komplett alles hier vollkleistern mit Baobab?
Ich meine, es gab mal so Produkte von Shark Tank.
Du hast ja knickere ich mit dem.
Das wird jetzt schon eher fast ein Brei.
Danke, reicht.
Vielen Dank.
So, hier, von wegen Snack Education.
Wir sind der eigentliche Snack-Podcast.
Geht auf gar keinen Fall zu denen.
Wir müssen die Konkurrenz sofort einarbeiten.
Und hier haben wir Stefan Tietze mit seinem Snack-Review zum Thema Baobab-Pulver, der Affenbrotbaum aus fernen Landen.
Welches Fernland denn?
Paragonien, ist es Parolinien?
Madagaskar. Ja, cheers! Jetzt stellt euch vor, ein nicht neodefiniertes Pulver wird in Wasser gefüllt und der Geruch ist es tatsächlich wieder. Sehr neutral. Wahnsinn. Super, ne?
Ist es super oder super oder flop? Ist es flopfood oder superfood?
Ich bin ja kein Fan dieser ganzen Nahrungsergänzungsmittel, superfood Geschichte.
Ich muss aber sagen, das schmeckt nicht schlecht es schmeckt
sauer es ist ein bisschen zitronig aber auch hat eine gewisse süsse also fast wie eine so
eine instant limonade ja aber super also ist es super oder ist es nicht super? Gibt es so ein Average Food? Average Food. Average Food. Average Food. Ja, Math Food. Okay, alles klar, gut. Wie findest du es denn? Ich habe es bis jetzt nur in Joghurt reingerührt und so wenig, dass ich es nicht schmecke eigentlich, weil ich ... Ich musste beim ersten Geruch tatsächlich an Basketball denken. So dieser etwas so gummihafte, sterile, so auch wie bei unseren Tennisbällen. Die haben nochmal einen sehr eigenen Geruch. Riechen toll. Die riechen richtig toll, aber es hat so einen, ja, künstlichen Geruch so ein bisschen. Kann aber auch sein, dass ich oben in der Packung direkt am Plastikverschluss gerochen habe. Kann natürlich auch sein, man riecht ja am Ende auch immer seine Nase, also da sind ja ganz viele Faktoren, die da noch mit drin sind. Bei diesem Wein bekomme ich Glas, Glasgeruch. So wie bei allen anderen Weinen auch, Herr Tietze? Ja, ich muss eingestehen, dass mir viele Weine schmecken, riechen erstmal gleich, Gläsern. Also ein bisschen fleischlich, wie so ein bisschen, wie so ein Riechorgan, so ein bisschen.
Ich bilde mir immer ein, dass ich einen guten Geschmacksinn habe und einen guten Geruchssinn. Du sagst ja von dir aus, hast du gar nicht beides. Ich bilde mir immer ein, dass ich das sehr gut riechen kann und auch schmecken kann. Aber es ist auch eine Bürde, die man trägt. Oh, das tut mir so, weil du so intensiv schmeckst, weil du so anspruchsvoll bist dann auch. Nein, das gar nicht, aber wenn man irgendwo essen geht oder was trinkt, Wasser, schmecke ich oft Ei. Und ich kann dir sagen, dieses Glas wurde mit fucking so Rühreipfanne. Da war mal ein Ei drin. Nee, nicht unbedingt. In der Spülmaschine war eine Pfanne, in der Eier gemacht wurden, so Rühreier oder so ein Kram. Und selbst wenn ich das bei mir mache... Du kannst kleinste Eispüren noch wahrnehmen. Aber du bist so eine Art, es gibt ja so hochspezialisierte Spürhunde, die dann so Leichen finden und so, auch ewig lang danach oder Drogen. Du bist so eine Art Eispür. Eispürmürmensch du könntest tatsächlich wenn mal ein paar eier verloren gehen wenn mal irgendwie sagt ja gut ich weiß nicht wie heißt eine firma der osterhase sagen wir mal ich hab hier ich hab hier zwei lkw ladung eier habe ich verloren ich rufe den stefan an stefan du alter alter alter hasenbengel du jetzt der Osterhase hi du ich habe ich habe zwei finden ihre Eier ich habe zwei Lkw Eier verloren die sind nur auf der acht falsch abgebogen oder so schwing dich mal in dein Eimobil und find mir die mein Junge Tietze fall aufgenommen ach einfach da hinten wohin einfach da in der Lichtung. Ah, die Lichtung. Ja, die Lichtung. Ja, die Lichtung. Am Ende ist es immer bei der Lichtung. Die Lichtung. Es ist entweder in Hörspielen ist immer, das war, ich sag mal, zwei Wörter, die haben immer grosse Fragezeichen bei mir ausgelöst. weil so, ich weiß nicht, ob es dir auch so ging, bei Benjamin Blümchen, drei Fragezeichen, so damals hat man beim Kassettenhören so, oder beim, also nicht so, alte Hörspiele hören, gab so ein paar Wörter, wo ich immer dachte, ich hab immer rege Fantasie gehabt, konnte mir alles vorstellen, und diese beiden Wörter, blank, ich wusste nicht mehr, was passiert hier, ich kann dem Plot nicht mehr folgen, und es war einmal Lichtung, ich wusste schlicht nicht, im Wald tauchte eine Lichtung auf. Es kam an eine Lichtung, ja. Bei mir war es immer eine Art Berg, bin ich ehrlich, eine vage, eine vage Anhöhung und es war direkt viel heller. Ja, mit Licht, ja, ja, aber es ist nicht die Definition von Lichtung. Was ist, Struppi, ich sehe dich doch kaum noch. Doch plötzlich blieb Struppi stehen und Tim konnte zu ihm aufschliessen. Und er sah, warum Struppi stehen geblieben war. Er tritt nach vorne. Warum? Wohin? Und war in einem Hain. Was? Wo? Was? Und dann so ein Wunder. Stefan, Stefan, was ist los? Warum hast du mir ein Hörspiel nicht verstanden? Ja, ich weiß nicht, wo Sie sind. Sie stehen auf einem Hain. Was ist ein Hain? Und Struppi sagte, so einen schönen Hain habe ich noch nie gesehen. Halt auf, das Wort zu benutzen. So war ich als. Plus ein anderes Wort! Bitte! Umschreibt es! Bitte! Gib mir eine Metapher! Bitte! Umschreibt es! Ein Hain wie was? Benutz Hain in dem Satz! Benutz Hain in einem anderen Satz als wir sind hier in einem Hain! Ja, der Hain sieht so aus wie... Also Lichtung in Hain... Also Lichtung fand ich gut. und das andere Wort ist Verschlag.
Ja, Verschlag ist auch gut, ja. Verschlag ist super, ja.
Verschlag habe ich immer nicht verstanden.
Er muss da hinten in dem Verschlag sein.
Und dann sind sie da hinten, da hinten ist ein Knistern zu hören.
Und so gingen sie hin, langsam wagten sie sich vor, der Nebel umschloss den Wald langsam, das Mondlicht durchbrach nur manchmal die Wolken, und dann kamen sie an, und sie trauten ihren Augen nicht. Es war genau der Bretterverschlag, den sie gesucht haben. Was, was, Mama, was, nein, benutzt ein anderes Wort, bitte, was, was ist es? Weil meine, hier ist blank, es ist wie so ein Videospiel, wo so etwas nicht geladen hat.
Genau, ja, es glitscht so raus. Ich sehe genau, das Licht ist perfekt und ich sehe, wie sie dann mit verschiedenen Kamera-Angels, kann ich mir so vorstellen, wie sie durch das Unterholz, Unterholz auch lustig, aber so durch das in den Wald laufen. Und dann sehe ich, und dann sehen sie das Ding und ich habe da kein Bild für. Und dann ist es wie so ein, wie ein, wie entweder so ein Fragezeichen oder so ein nicht gerendertes, verpixeltes Ding. Ja, es ist schon verrückt, vor allem für Kinder müssen ja die meisten Geschichten, ich glaube deswegen haben Kinder auch so viel Fantasie, weil sie ständig Lücken füllen müssen, weil sonst ständig irgendwie bei jeder Buchseite, äh Mutter, ganz kurz kurz. Muttern. Muttern, ähm, du hast gerade...
Muttern habe ich gesagt, sollst du mich nennen.
Du hast gerade gesagt, Captain Blaubeer legte an
an einem Atoll. Jetzt,
ähm, bedenke,
Mutter, ich bin fünfeinhalb Jahre.
Im August
wären es fünf Komma sechs.
Erleuchte mich.
Ach so, die hat jemand gewonnen.
Was ist ein Atoll? Atoll ist sowas wie, ähm, erleuchte mich. Ach so, die hat jemand gewonnen. Er, erleuchte mich. Was ist ein Atoll? Atoll ist sowas wie, ähm, Lagune. Und so schwommen sie weiter durch das Atoll. Mutter, eine weitere Unterbrechung, die du bitte entschuldigen möchtest. Du hast gerade gesagt Lagune. Bedenke bitte, fünfeinhalb Jahre ist nicht lang. Ich lebe noch nicht lange auf dieser Erde und ich habe noch nicht so viel mitbekommen. Die ersten Jahre sind komplett schwarz. Deswegen hier nochmal der Wunsch von mir an dich. Bitte nimm Rücksicht darauf, dass ich die meisten Worte nicht kenne. Lagune ist eines davon. Bitte erkläre es mir, was ist eine Lagune? Also ist ein Riff. Und so schwommen beide durch die... Mutter, eine letzte Unterbrechung für den heutigen Abend, hoffe ich. Es ist den heutigen Abend. Ja, es ist schwierig, da muss man einfach ständig Lücken füllen. So wie bei Pokémon, wo dann auch irgendwie ständig dann die Gegner, und es war dann einfach Teenager und Gentlemann. Und ich dachte mir, der Gentlemann halt. Der ist halt Gentle, ne? Also, ja, wird schon frasen. Ich habe so ein Stephen King-Buch sehr früh gelesen, zu früh, würde ich rückblickend sagen, und da habe ich immer gedacht, das spielt alles in Massachussetz. Massachussetz. Massachussetz. Und irgendwann habe ich meine Eltern gefragt, ähm, das ist irgendwie, ging es dann um den Inhalt des Buches und ich habe gefragt, wo liegt der eigentlich Masajussetz und beide so, was?
Idiot, wir haben Idiot, Flopkind, Flopkind, schlechtest-Kind, ha, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he, he Zurück auf die Stube. Die was?
Aber das war wirklich hochbelustigend für mich.
Immer diese Wörter, wo man das nicht verstanden hat,
dann war man irgendwie lost.
In seiner kleinen Welt.
In seiner kleinen, kleinen Welt.
In einem kleinen Hügel.
Ja, wir brechen auf.
Wohin?
In den Weltraum.
In den Kosmos. Haben wir nie geklärt. Die Lore ist nicht geklärt. Die Lore ist nicht geklärt, weil... Bleiben wir in dem Orbit oder verlassen wir sogar den Orbit? Der Kosmos ist unendlich gross. Sind wir auf anderen Planeten, haben wir da auch Podcasts? Der Kosmos ist unendlich gross. Und Stefan, all diese Fragen können sich unsere Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer beantworten, wenn sie einfach kurz aus dem Fenster schauen. Denn dann sehen sie die unendlichen Weiten der Galaxien. Und vielleicht ein kleines Licht um das Podcast-Uvo.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ciao, macht's gut, ihr Lieben.
Schöne Woche!
Leben ab, tschüss!